flash was
better I say that because Flash gets a
lot of [__] enjoy the flash or hate the
flash regardless flash was better at the
very least more cohesive why do I ruin
my reviews in the first few seconds I
don't know I never said I was good at
this YouTube thing but YouTube thing I
do so let's do the YouTube
[Music]
thing so
Aquaman 2 lost Dynasty and the lost
kingdom I was almost sorry Aquaman and
the lost kingdom is the sequel to The
billion dooll Blockbuster Aquaman this
is once again directed by James Juan we
have Arthur Curry teaming up with his
brother orm Black Manta has returned
more powerful than ever but there's more
to it than that I'll get into it in a
second so in terms of production this
movie has been a schoras board of rumor
mill early screenings were abysmal
people said it was unreleasable rumors
of re-shoot happening which actually
does track there are moments in this
movie I was like why does everyone feel
like they're reading off of Q cards that
would make sense if they felt they were
done and then oh hey re-shoot can you
come back all right they come back
where's my script don't worry about it
we just got to hammer this out there's
the Q card go I can see re-shoot
happening I can see that being the
reason it feels like that or the
dialogue just sucks there's that but
early on this movie obviously suffered
from an identity crisis this movie is a
buddy comedy sometimes this tongue and
cheek slapstick sometimes it wants to be
badass sometimes and dramatic it's
successful at being none of these things
because it doesn't pick a path and
commit to it there is a comedic moment
or two that did make me laugh just like
there's this trident battle between
Aquaman and black man at the end that I
thought was pretty cool brief instances
all of them because in the end they're
still thrown into this weird mess of a
movie the plot of this movie I've
already seen people call it essentially
Dollar Store mummy Tomb of the Dragon
Emperor fair for me because some of the
visuals really reminded me of the intro
to Mortal Kombat deception for me it
reminded me of dollar sto and a gash
from Warhammer was working through Black
Manta to raise both him and onaga's
dragon Army if Dollar Store Nash was a
villain in Captain Planet because the
plot is very Captain Planet and the
pacing of this m man this movie is about
2 hours long the first Aquaman was 2 and
1 half hours long this movie should have
at least been that long possibly 3 hours
like example Aquaman's going to go get
orm they Montage through with a voice
over explaining what they're going to do
and just kind of picks up when he's in
the room with them maybe a little before
that was clearly where they shaved some
time but shaving that time compromised
that scene that could have been a cool
infiltration scene in the end it well
just feels like the rest of the movie it
happened I guess Manta ends up with this
advanced yet ancient sub and a crew of
people to run it where' he get the
people how' they train how did he train
them we don't know it just happened just
have a little text that says five month
months later don't question it movie
just felt so disjointed you have a movie
that's about 2 hours long that feels
about an hour longer than that I was
checking my watch so much in this movie
at a point I was like okay we're coming
up to the last Act only if wow oh my God
we're only an hour in we're halfway
through like I basically have to sit
here for as long as I've already sat
here again yeah this movie [__] the bad
speaking of which Amber herd's in the
movie kind of it's one of the rumors
about the movie is like they're kind of
cutting Amber heard from the movie but
she's still in the movie you saw the
trailer you're like oh there's no there
she is though she is terrible in this
movie for the limited screen time she
has a lot of people are because there's
just [__] dialogue in here there's this
one scene where something happens and
everyone's all no no
no I was
like where the [__] am I right now I
mean Amber herd's part was clearly cut
down in this movie there's no reality No
statement I'm going to hear a official
or otherwise that's going to make me
believe no this is how it was supposed
to be from the beginning a movie
revolving around Arthur Curry's family
in which she just kind of has minimal
screen time and the screen time she has
she has very minimal dialogue her
character in this movie feels like when
you throw a party at your house and
there's that one person that just hangs
around and doesn't leave you got to have
the one-on-one with them like look it's
time to go I'm tired she was there with
nothing to do felt like one of those
characters you just can't help but think
why have her here also this movie's in
3D wild get every penny they can back
that's for sure we all saw the bad CGI
in the trailer I get it it can't all be
James Cameron it can't all be way of
water but I feel like way of water just
kind of broke me in a sense when it
doesn't look that good it just breaks
the immersion but speaking of immersion
there were so many scenes where people
were just standing around while they
were talking in the ocean like they're
in atlantiss just standing around or
sitting down I get it actors hate being
on those wires to be in underwater
scenes
I'm sure it's obnoxious that said from
the viewer standpoint it just wasn't
immersive I had to look at their hair to
see if their hair was floating to see if
they were underwater or not cuz they
just stand around on land or stand
around underwater since most of the
underwater scenes like some battles
aside there are scenes where people swim
of course no one's on cables no one's
suspended no one's floating it doesn't
feel like they're underwater when
they're underwater and the plot of this
movie really compromised the only thing
I was really looking forward to seeing
which was manta's Revenge Quest Manta
was a standout in the first movie I like
the fact that we were going to see more
of him in the second and here we go we
see the trailer Mor man Revenge Quest
not really because it's essentially
dollar stor the gash poisoning his mind
even talking through him by the end so
it's his revenge Quest though it does
say that's the motivation behind it in
execution it's not his revenge Quest
takes a side seat to Dollar Store NE
gash the store I don't know why I keep
calling him Dollar Store NE gash I like
me the dead and War Hammer that's why
there was one scene with Black Manta
where the lights were all off and you
just see the red eyes light up I was
like that's it that's James Juan
bringing something to this movie this is
when you see the Fingerprints of James
Juan I got to say it's the only time I
saw that creepy moment intimidating
figure movie wasn't trying to be some
weird buddy comedy Fallen flat it was a
good moment should have had more moments
like that but yeah it was a real bummer
that the Revenge tale really isn't
what's happening not that any of it
matters really it's leading to what it's
leading to what nothing it's done it's
over this is the funeral of the DCU
really Arthur Curry's Arc sucks in this
movie I mean I guess you can call it an
arc retcon from the first movie look at
the first movie he made no secrets about
it he didn't want to go to Atlantis he
did not want the Throne of Atlantis but
he had no choice but I still felt like
by the end he was like oh hey this is my
destiny and I'm a king and I'm going to
be a good King and Aquaman 2 apparently
they had to backtrack on all that to
give Arthur the illusion of complexity
so he once again doesn't want the job
though he likes telling people I'm the
king of Atlantis hell yeah which is ego
at that point CU he likes the title his
heart isn't in it and he's had this job
for a while it makes you question
whether or not he is the guy for the job
you're the [__] King man this is a
big deal if your heart's not in it if
you're not committed pick someone else
like in the end maybe there's a better
3-hour cut of this movie but unlike
Napoleon I'm uninterested to see what
that would look like for this the
characters are a bunch of nothing
Burgers they have no development they're
just kind of
there cuz the better villain of black
manta's Revenge Quest has been wasted
for another villain that you've just
never heard about until now the CGI
looks cartoonish there are moments of
Patrick Wilson and Jason mimoa not
enough to save it though not by a long
shot too much going on not enough time
to flesh any of it out nobody's going to
remember this final nail this death
rattle of the dceu not in T-minus one
day yep already forgot so Aquaman in the
lost kingdom have you seen it have you
seen the end of the DC euu or what is
your favorite DCU movie whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
[Music]
more